[Musik]
wartet man noch gar nicht bereit
sich nicht so weit ich brauche nur ein
moment
hallo ihr lieben und wir machen heute
was amerikanisches denn ich bin
aufgeregt werdet ihr dieses video seht
bin ich hier in amerika bisher gesagt in
new york zusammen mit kaufland und was
wir da machen erfahrt ihr dann in den
nächsten monaten und ich habe für dieses
video heute überlegt möchte irgendwas
amerikanische ich liebe amerikanische
küche und gerade was süßes angeht
deshalb machen wir kiel ein paar
kilos also eigentlich ist kelheim sind
die limetten und es gibt die den kielern
bei das ist halt eine reform der runde
und ich mache aber was also schmitten
quasi und wir starten direkt ich
schreibe euch wie immer alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben hier unten in die
infobox könnte das ganze screenshot und
direkt einkaufen gehen das rezept ist
super einfach und schnell gemacht nur
die kürzer dauert ein bisschen aber das
ist kein problem
ich habe jetzt hier dinkel butterkekse
im amerikanischen nimmt man die graham
cracker das sind vollkornkekse und ich
finde die als ersatz gibt vorwirft
durchaus
ein bisschen aufgeregt weil ich bin ja
jetzt stand jetzt bin ich dass ich bin
ich da gerade in new york aber stand
jetzt bin ich in drei tagen in new york
um ein englisches ein bisschen
eingerostet
das kriege ich hin ein paar englische
netflix syrien unterwegs
[Musik]
so die kekse habe ich jetzt fein gemixt
wenn ihr nicht so nicht gehabt dann
nimmt einfach ein gefriert und haut
richtig fest darauf dass alle ihre
aggressionen raus und dann habe ich noch
butter zerlassen bei geringer aber sonst
platzt ist solch eine mikrowelle ich
jetzt auch noch mit dazu und ganz
typisch ist dafür dass man hier jetzt
dinkel kekse verwendet oder auch die
graham trecker dass man auch noch ein
bisschen zucker mit rein gibt und später
wenn man das noch mal kurz anpackt dann
schmeckt es einfach noch mal besser und
karamellisiert ein bisschen
[Musik]
der boden ist jetzt einmal im backend
komplett fest angedrückt und jetzt wird
er noch vorgebacken bei 175 grad circa
zehn minuten dann rausholen wieder
abkühlen lassen und ich zeige euch auf
eine zwischenzeit die leckere zitronen
die mettenschicht dies nämlich im mega
schnell gemacht
[Musik]
so für die füllung brauchen wir nicht
viele zutaten zuallererst müssen wir
eher trennen eiweiß brauchen wir bei
diesem rezept nicht das könnte ich aber
auch bewahren ich mache zum beispiel
ganz gern also ich esse tatsächlich
rohes frisches eiweiß und schlagt mir
das einfach mit ein bisschen zucker oder
mit re tritt auf und dann esse ich das
so als fleisch ich weiß das hört sich
sehr lecker und hier brauchen wir aber
nur gelb und das gebe ich dann gleich
einfach hier in meinem küchenmaschine
und lass es 34 minuten lang richtig
schön hell cremig schlagen und gibt dann
gibt sogar die kondensmilch dazu
[Musik]
so ein gap und gezuckerte kondensmilch
sind jetzt verhört worden das ganze hat
ungefähr 56 minuten gedauert mit der
maschine geht es immer ein bisschen
schneller und jetzt brauchen wir
natürlich das essentielle nämlich
zitronen und limetten ich mach das mal
gern so dass ich wirklich beides nehmen
die zitronen geben einfach mehr saft ab
aber limetten sind halt auch essenziell
weil ihr noch mal ein bisschen anders
schmecken und dann nimmt er am besten
bio zitrone und bio die metten weil da
dürft ihr die schale mit verwenden und
dann müsst ihr darauf achten nimmt eine
fein reiben und treibt nicht nochmal
unter der grünen haut da kommt nehme ich
dann eine weiße und die schmeckt bitter
und das dürft ihr nicht mit rein reiben
spreche gilt auch für zitronen dann und
die gelbe haut verwenden und nicht
darunter die weiße wir uns schmeckt
bitter und dann ja habt ihr alles
umsonst gemacht was kann man dann auch
nicht mehr retten und da gebe ich dann
gleich auch noch den saft reines messe
ich mir hier ab weil in jeder limette
und in jeder zitrone ist ja
unterschiedlich viel saft drinnen und
dass man sich wie gesagt mit der wagen
ab und schreibe ich alle ganz genau wenn
man dann natürlich und linie infobox
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt einmal der saure saftige
süße mischung bringt noch richtig
richtig gute kombi und da kommt jetzt
auch noch doppel rahm frischkäse dazu
und stattdessen könnt ihr auch
mascarpone verwenden also es könnte 1 1
ersetzen das ist kein problem das ganze
jetzt vielleicht noch mal mit dem
schneebesen aus als gut verrühren so
kurz wie notwendig also so lange wie
notwendig dass es einfach eine homogene
masse wird und dann kommt das auf dem
boden
[Musik]
soll das ganze ist jetzt zurück
gewandert in den backofen backzeit
schreibe ich euch hier auf jeden fall
noch mit rein und anschließend
vollständig auskühlen das nicht steht es
hier noch an der spülmaschine und gibt
noch hier die restlichen zitronen und
limetten rest einfach mit rein ist
einfach für die maschine dass sie gut
riecht und anschließend könnte sie
entsorgen
[Musik]
so ich habe das ganze jetzt ca 2 stunden
kühlen lassen erst auf zimmertemperatur
anschließend noch ein stündchen in den
kühlschrank je nachdem die kalte
eingestellt ist kann auch drei stunden
brauchen ist das schön fest wird aber es
ist unfassbar
ohne stärke ist es komplett fest
geworden das liegt einfach am
zitronensaft und ami metten saft und sie
werden auch später also man kann sie
fast sogar schon mit den händen essen
sind so richtige bars also so richtige
die sagt bürgerfest bars auf deutsch
riegel wie regel ja und ich kann mir
auch gar nicht vorstellen wie es ist
wenn ich in amerika will leute ihr könnt
mir jetzt auf instagram folgen falls ihr
das nicht verpassen möchte denn ich
mache mit sicherheit auf stories gerade
wo ich da bin und ich könnte mir nochmal
schreiben auf ihr schon mal in amerika
war und falls ja wo das ist ja unendlich
riesig so gehe ich mal ganz kurz in die
spüle und dann schneide ich mir jetzt
einfach zurecht ich habe mir ja noch
sahne aufgeschlagen einfach nur frische
schlagsahne zusammen mit sahne fürs süße
brauchte ich da jetzt gar nicht mehr
sind schneide ich mir das wie gesagt zu
recht der kurier noch mit sahne und mit
limetten abrieb und vielleicht gebe ich
auch noch richtige
[Musik]
soll die rolle von der kiko probiert
jetzt fragen sie den ehrliche meinung ja
richtig gut dann können wir vom du
verliebst du bist eigentlich
alles liest sieht die gäste
also fazit alles gut geschmeckt
unbedingt nachmachen wir machen jetzt
feierabend reicht für heute
[Musik]